**Susan Daniels**: Welcome back from break this is day to afternoon session, the second of three in the afternoon we're still working on schedule management.
**Susan Daniels**: And we're going to move into schedule compression techniques and then conclude um we have one more break before we are done for the night, and the last thing will be budget and quality.
**Susan Daniels**: So thank you guys for using that chat, for you know peer to peer during break so let's resume our norm of only using the chat for dialogue, relative to current topics in the lecture.
**Susan Daniels**: I don't know about you, but I have found this and much more pleasant day with the zoom and the ability to engage with each other so like to know whether overall you guys see you think this is working.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so we've covered leveling and smoothing okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Now we're going to talk about schedule compression techniques and there's really fundamentally two types, there is crashing and fast tracking.
**Susan Daniels**: And the crushing what is on this slide is helping you know the key takeaways from crashing.
**Susan Daniels**: not exactly how to do it, but some key takeaways, which is that it only works for activities on the critical path.
**Susan Daniels**: You only are focused and when you go to crash or compress your schedule you start first on that critical path looking elsewhere other work streams.
**Susan Daniels**: might be helpful, but it's still not going to change the series independent of activities that are pushing out the total duration of your project or identifying your early finish.
**Susan Daniels**: So you stay crushing requires looking at the critical path that's where you get the the the actual benefit.
**Susan Daniels**: On what you're trying to do is literally buy time out of your project when you in your notes, I want you to say you say crashing equals cost Okay, it always costs to crash.
**Susan Daniels**: Now there are different ways that we can look at buying time out of the schedule, some of them are pretty common, for example.
**Susan Daniels**: expedited delivery right instead of waiting for standard shipping getting expedited maybe we do some overtime right to make sure it gets done by the target date so that all the other activities that are coming in together to meet it this one's ready to go to right.
**Susan Daniels**: um but there's other things that you might do that produce too much risk yeah we could do it that's a pretty risky choice.
**Susan Daniels**: And so, when you're trying to crash, not all options are really viable sometimes it's just too risky so crushing is on what is considered, in my opinion, after you've you've tried doing fast tracking.
**Susan Daniels**: First, you fast track you look at your schedule and see where things are being done sequentially one after the other, and see where you might be able to make them start to occur more concurrently okay that doesn't generally cost money okay buddy does.
**Susan Daniels**: Definitely enter induce rework or the risk of rework and we give you the example of your coding the screens.
**Susan Daniels**: And once you get all the screens coded and you've kind of locked in that segment of your program, then you start to write the user guy.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, you decide that you need to compress your schedule and you're going to try to move writing the user manual kind of in parallel.
**Susan Daniels**: not exactly day for day but kind of in parallel with on the coding the screens so maybe you're too after you do two screens, then you start to write your user manual right, and then the screens are being developed the user manuals going.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, what happens when you started writing the user manual after the second screen and on screen seven stakeholders go, oh no we've got to add this and it's an approved change.
**Susan Daniels**: But now the real estate on that screen doesn't fit on all the items that they want on that screen for screen seven not all the items fit.
**Susan Daniels**: So now they're going to move some things and talk them over to a different one that was already developed which then shifts to the previous one that was developed and is having a ripple effect in the code and design.
**Susan Daniels**: Well that's one problem but secondarily now you have to rework all of your user manuals guidance as well, so when you go to compress something that was logically one thing after another, because it made good sense okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Just know that you're always at risk for rework when you do fast tracking here is a couple of videos on crashing and fast tracking.
Imagine that you are at a racetrack and one of the race cars comes in for a pit stop, in addition to fuel the car needs new tires.
The spectators watch as a single pit crew member changes each tire one by one, and after about 25 minutes, the car returns to the track, unfortunately, the races already over what went wrong.
Sometimes, time is a constraint that can't be negotiated a new ski gondola must be installed before opening day.
A new cruise ship must be ready to transport passengers who booked their voyage, a year in advance and a bride's dress must be completed before her wedding day.
When a project timeline is critical meeting that timeline may require additional resources and additional resources means additional costs.
Now let's get back to that pitstop isn't it more likely that there would be eight highly skilled crew members to per tire working to quickly get that race car back on the track in order to win the race.
This is an example of schedule crashing a scheduled compression technique when you need to compress or reduce the duration of an activity, you may assign more resources to it.
When we designate additional resources for an activity in order to compress the schedule, it comes at a cost crashing is expensive, but it is a great option if your schedule is the top constraint, for your project.
It is important to understand that not every activity can be crashed activities such as downloading files or backing up servers cannot be compressed by adding more resources, however, for the remainder of this discussion we're going to assume that the activities can be crashed.
let's say that today is June 1 and you're in the middle of a 12 month project, everything has been progressing well, and your project is on schedule.
You are also proud of the fact that you've been coming in under budget, then you receive a visit from your sponsor that changes everything.
Your sponsor says due to unexpected circumstances, we must finish this project, one month early, we must finished by the end of November, no matter what it costs just get it done.
Think of this scenario, in the context of crashing it today is June 1, how can you best utilize this technique, to finish your project, a month ahead of time if you'd like more time to think about your answer just pause the video and resume when you're ready.
**Susan Daniels**: If you suggested, adding resources to the develop application activity that is the best answer.
**Susan Daniels**: Why, first of all, it only makes sense to crash activities that are on the critical path that is the only way to compress your overall schedule.
**Susan Daniels**: Also, the sooner you address the issue, the better the develop application activity is the only activity available to crash, since it is occurring right now.
**Susan Daniels**: If you wait too long the opportunity may slip away, you will continue to approach the final project activities which are on the critical path.
**Susan Daniels**: What exactly would you do to crash this activity and compress the project schedule feel free to pause the video at any time and resume when you're ready.
If you suggested, adding resources to the develop application activity, you are correct, the number of resources, you add can be determined using parametric estimating.
The more resources, you add the shorter the activity duration will be at least until the point of diminishing returns at some point, you will achieve the most efficient staffing level for the activity.
Any more resources will not result in a shorter duration once you estimate the appropriate number of resources to add this activity, you can determine the cost and update the schedule baseline and budget baselines accordingly.
In summary, crashing is a schedule compression technique that involves adding resources to an activity in order to reduce its duration crashing adds cost, but can be effective in getting your schedule back on track.
**Susan Daniels**: When creating our project schedule, we sequence activities based on logical relationships and dependencies some dependencies are mandatory, while others are discretionary or best practices.
**Susan Daniels**: Think about to routine maintenance activities that are common for car owners refueling and changing tires these activities are performed independently why.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, the equipment needed for each of these activities is a little different and many people choose to pump their own gas, while paying someone else to change their tires.
**Susan Daniels**: The fact that these activities are performed separately seems to be based on logic, however, there is one situation where a car is refueled at the same time, the tires are change because time is of the essence, can you think of the situation where both activities would happen concurrently.
You may pause the video at any time to determine the answer and then resume the video when you're ready to hear the correct answer.
**Susan Daniels**: If you set a pit stop you are right in the interest of saving time and getting the race car back on the track as quickly as possible the activities of pumping gas and changing tires is performed simultaneously.
**Susan Daniels**: There is no time to waste now this pit crew is highly trained and specialized imagine what might happen if you attempted to refuel your car, at the same time, your tires were being changed.
**Susan Daniels**: For starters, there would probably be some mistakes as people gotten one another's way and accidentally bumped into each other.
**Susan Daniels**: We could be introducing safety issues, since we are dealing with flammable materials, and we would be attempting to perform two activities at the same time, when there is a logical reason to do them one, at a time.
performing activities simultaneously that were previously intended to be performed in sequence is a schedule compression technique called fast tracking.
And although there are definite risks and pitfalls to using fast tracking there could also be great advantages to your schedule, if you need to get things done faster let's consider an example.
let's say that today is June 1 and you are in the middle of a 12 month project, everything has been progressing well, and your project is on schedule.
Then you receive a visit premier sponsor that changes everything your sponsor says due to unexpected circumstances, we must finish this project, one month early.
We must be finished by the end of November, also there was no money in the budget for crashing the schedule, you have to do this without spending additional funds.
Think of this scenario, in the context of fast tracking if today is June 1 we want to best utilize this technique, to finish the project, a month ahead of time.
The first thing we want to do is consider activities on the critical path it makes sense to compress the duration of the critical path, because that is the only way to compress your overall schedule.
without knowing the attributes of these activities let's assume that all of the dependencies are discretionary it's probably a best practice to perform them in sequence, but they don't have to be.
Can you determine how we might use fast tracking to compress our schedule feel free to pause the video at any time and resume when you're ready.
There are a few options here one of them is to perform activities E and F, in parallel, or, at the same time, instead of in sequence, as they were originally planned.
By performing these activities together, you can compress the schedule by one month and finish the project by the end of November as instructed by your sponsor.
If you were thinking about starting activity D before activity see was finished or performing activity at the same time as activity D, these are also possible options.
Before determining exactly which activities can be fast tracked you would review the activity attributes to determine why the dependencies were there in the first place, and why the activities were sequenced in this manner.
You certainly don't want to ignore a mandatory dependency that was placed there by a key stakeholder.
Because of the added risks that fast tracking introduces to a project, it is important for the project manager to consult with key stakeholders and to seek expert judgment.
Together, you can identify the risks plan risk responses and assess the impact on any other areas of the project.
You will submit a change request and utilize the integrated change control so that the schedule baseline and any relevant project documents can be updated.
In summary, fast tracking is a scheduled compression technique that can be used to reduce the duration of your schedule, it should be carefully considered because of the added risk it can introduce to your project.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so um there was a comment that came up in the chat about that I said i'm to try to fast track before you try to crash, and it usually just has to do with resource actual financial resources being available to your project.
**Susan Daniels**: If you don't have additional resources is probably because you didn't develop a risk register that then had your contingency funds justified to be added to your project.
**Susan Daniels**: So one of the things that you might put in your risk register is the potential need for overtime and what would be the driver of that so your additional money that you would use for crashing sometimes comes from the projects risk registers and contingency fund.
**Susan Daniels**: You want, if you don't have any additional resources fast tracking is something that you can do like I said that doesn't automatically cost money.
**Susan Daniels**: crashing is always trying to buying time out of your schedule, whether it's over time expedited shipping sending it out to a vendor to have done while we keep working on the primary skill set that we've got to get it done and have them come back and and deliver something for us.
**Susan Daniels**: That always cost money and that's my my rationale, so if somebody tells you, you know.
**Susan Daniels**: we're going to you have to crush this, you have to crush your schedule right, you know and they think they are talking project management talk to you, you can go great are certainly start to start to work on that, but i'm going to see what I can fast track first.
**Susan Daniels**: And then i'll often you know kind of given get this one oh OK so maybe there's a way to do this without spending money, and there is right, so it just is knowing these options is what makes you a professional in the field that you don't always have to throw money at the problem.
**Susan Daniels**: So this is a key point, and sometimes it's overlooked, we get very myopic very focused on our project, so please bear in mind that your project might be part of a whole program or portfolio of projects and there may be dependencies on what you're producing and.
**Susan Daniels**: You need to put that in context right if i'm accelerating to try to make sure I hit my deadline that's great if I don't hit it.
**Susan Daniels**: I need to understand the consequences to the other other projects in my program and in my portfolio which oftentimes can help you justify getting the money to do you're crashing right if i'm late.
**Susan Daniels**: Which is kind of embarrassing, but if i'm at risk of being late here's the ripple effect for the whole portfolio or for at least my program of projects and programs or projects is multiple projects that share a common.
**Susan Daniels**: platform client group geographic location something in common that makes working them all together have synergies and cost cost savings and efficiencies.
**Susan Daniels**: They often share common resources, so if i'm late it often has a ripple effect in my program so that's what this slide is about it can work for you to take it to the larger context to justify money.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so.
**Susan Daniels**: um give me a second, I want to.
**Susan Daniels**: take up there, we go I lost chat there for a minute.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: just want to reiterate that we're using Q amp a for technical issues we're using breaks for.
**Susan Daniels**: Peer to peer conversations and we're using chat during presentations for topic specific quiet Q and.
**Susan Daniels**: Q amp a with me and if I don't answer your question peers, can you know jump in and help answer questions, but it moves slow enough that people can see what's going on, and I can see what's going on, and it makes it a much more engaging experience for all parties involved.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm just facts tracking on have a potential impact on scope consider there's no additional budget and time has been shortened.
**Susan Daniels**: On your fast tracking trying to keep all all the work done right is the schedule compression technique.
**Susan Daniels**: It is not going to change your scope, you still have to get done what you're expected to get done justin less time now Okay, so if you're fast tracking and with no additional money.
**Susan Daniels**: The greatest resource or tool you've got to fast track is persuasion.
**Susan Daniels**: Right what's in it for them to be able to try to work harder and faster sooner, because you can't bribe them, you can only influence them to get the work done faster sooner and better what's in it for them.
**Susan Daniels**: But it doesn't change scope if we could have achieved these efficiencies to parallel efforts all along, without jeopardizing the project all along, why would we have needed the clients compression guidance to tell us to do so.
**Susan Daniels**: Because again there's soft logic on why you're trying to do things the way you planned it sequentially there was on, shall we say, general wisdom of the team that this was the wisest way to go forward.
**Susan Daniels**: But because you have the Opera because your schedule is being compressed, then you have to be more creative than you have to take the higher risk of doing it concurrently it's not something you would choose to do because of the risk factor of rework and that's why.
**Susan Daniels**: I do trust that you would try to do it the most efficient way, but not always, the riskiest way right the most efficient with the lowest risk it'll be your original plan.
**Susan Daniels**: Does Okay, I understand your question you sent it to me twice, so now I get it i'm Susan impact the quality assurance.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh yeah definitely that puts your quality assurance team on double time because now they're having to work on things sooner than they thought and chances are there may be.
**Susan Daniels**: higher risk for error, because we're human and if we work too fast and too hard, we have a tendency to make mistakes right.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Should the risk potential of fast tracking crashing addressed in resource management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm not exactly sure where you're going with that to me risk this risks would be put in your risk register, but we haven't covered risk register yet.
**Susan Daniels**: But that's where I would capture it and that's where I would get the money to be able to do my crashing i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: What I put in my resource management plan, I might identify in my resource management plan opportunity spaces, where I may be able to employ over time right like this particular.
**Susan Daniels**: activities would lend itself well to or this work package with Linda self well to applying over time, so I might mention it there, but it's not a requirement that I would put it there.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay gang i'm going to take one last question then we're going to definitely start getting into budget okay.
**Susan Daniels**: don't understand that one on there.
**Susan Daniels**: um i'm gonna i'm gonna have to defer on the two questions that I got from mark and Timothy i'll try to maybe look at those when we go through the next video and i'll give it more thought.
**Susan Daniels**: And we apply on change management to schedule compression.
**Susan Daniels**: Typically, not it's all the same scope that has to be done it's just how we're doing it it's not what it's changing it's not the scope is changing.
**Susan Daniels**: And that's when we use change management when we're changing scope, the requirements, none of us been changed, we still got to get done what we committed to do you just have to do it in less time so flipping to.
**Susan Daniels**: The we're managing costs now right we've shifted gears entirely, this is a whole new segment, we are now into planning manage budget and resources.
**Susan Daniels**: Much like schedule compression not doing our planning and managing schedule, we have a lot of tools and techniques that we use.
**Susan Daniels**: there's an acronym here that I want to spell out for you, it is called pimp your pins okay your project management information system.
**Susan Daniels**: Translation the tools and software's that you're going to use to manage your budget Okay, so you would leverage whatever accounts payable accounts receivable payroll system your.
**Susan Daniels**: Whatever budgeting software that you have right that's all part of your pmi is your pens down here costs variance earned value management estimate at completion.
**Susan Daniels**: These acronyms we're going to go deeper on, we have a whole lecture on earned value management and i'm calculating estimates that completion, when we talk about controlling the budget right now we're not controlling it because we haven't even built it yet right but.
**Susan Daniels**: We when we're building it we keep these things in mind okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So cost estimating will cost estimating we've talked about estimating.
**Susan Daniels**: And estimating the resources we need estimating the duration of our activities and our schedules and now we're going to do cost estimating again our use estimating again when it comes to doing our budget, and there are a variety of them okay.
**Susan Daniels**: A C stands for estimate at completion, but much more on that to come, please don't don't go don't be concerned at this point okay we're going to go on on our value management estimate completion and how to do all of that, when we're controlling the budget.
**Susan Daniels**: There are different ways that we can estimate and this slide is a nice summary of what the next arm.
**Susan Daniels**: What the next video is all about so give me a moment and i'm going to get the on the next video cued up.
**Susan Daniels**: And we will get a nice video on estimating techniques.
**Susan Daniels**: This day has been rich with videos so my my hat is off to to barb um.
**Susan Daniels**: let's take this.
**Susan Daniels**: Traditional estimating.
**Susan Daniels**: There are a few more estimating techniques that can be used to determine the costs of your project analogous estimates can come from lessons learned on past projects.
**Susan Daniels**: For instance, let's say that we're about to perform a software upgrade for a client we've done this work before so we're familiar with it, and there are very few unknowns.
**Susan Daniels**: The last two times we perform this work it cost $10,000 each time, so we can use this quick and inexpensive technique, to say that it will probably cost $10,000 this time as well.
**Susan Daniels**: And analogous estimate is also known as a top down estimate, because we don't need to go through the exercise of decomposing the work into a work breakdown structure or w yes.
**Susan Daniels**: And then perform the detailed bottom up estimate because there's a lot less effort in performing an analogous estimate, they tend to be quick and inexpensive.
**Susan Daniels**: One of the drawbacks of analogous estimates, is that they aren't always accurate, what if something has changed since the last time we perform this type of project.
**Susan Daniels**: Maybe the raw materials are more expensive now or the wages of the employees are higher it's also possible that this latest project could be less expensive.
**Susan Daniels**: Because we don't have to put so much effort into learning the work something to keep in mind is that analogous estimates, can also be used to estimate durations of activities, so this technique is also helpful when estimating the project schedule.
**Susan Daniels**: parametric estimates are another tool, you can use to estimate the cost of your project.
**Susan Daniels**: In parametric estimating there are different parameters, including the cost per hour the duration of the work and the number of resources performing the work.
**Susan Daniels**: As one parameter changes so does the overall estimate for the work, for instance let's say that a resource earns $35 per hour and they will be working on a task for 40 hours.
**Susan Daniels**: It will cost us 1400 dollars for that resource if we learn that the work will require two resources, we can double that amount, so it will cost $2,800 for both of the resources to work for 40 hours.
**Susan Daniels**: Three resources will cost 40 $200 and for resources will cost 50 $600.
**Susan Daniels**: That works fairly well, but one of the downsides to parametric estimating is that it comes with certain assumptions.
**Susan Daniels**: For instance, we're assuming that these resources, make the same hourly rate and that they work at roughly the same pace.
**Susan Daniels**: That may not be true, and any deviations from this assumption can result in less than accurate estimates.
**Susan Daniels**: Something to keep in mind is that parametric estimates, can also be used to estimate durations of activities, so this technique is also helpful when estimating the project schedule.
**Susan Daniels**: When estimating the quantity of resources necessary, we also have to consider the law of diminishing returns.
**Susan Daniels**: When estimating a task, there will always be a point where we don't get our money's worth by adding more and more resources will begin to lose efficiency and the value of each additional resource will decline.
**Susan Daniels**: there's no formula for the law of diminishing returns rather This is something that you and your project team will need to keep in mind as you estimate the resources needed for each task.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so there's a nice summary of the different kinds of estimating techniques, I do want to point out that analysis and parametric are considered top down kind of rapid more efficient ways of.
**Susan Daniels**: estimating and this cough tops down as opposed to bottoms up because you're taking an overview of the whole project going out and looking at different places from the top down, where you may need to get estimates to build your budget.
**Susan Daniels**: From bottoms up you go to the people, perhaps by using your work breakdown dictionary survey document.
**Susan Daniels**: People who are doing the work packages, asking them what resources do they need can give you optimistic most likely and pessimistic estimates and how much that would cost right.
**Susan Daniels**: And then you build your budget from the bottom up by summary someone all the work packages to reach the top right so that's very um.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me restart that sense is considered more accurate to do a bottoms up estimating However, the downside of that is time consuming right, it can be more time consuming to do a bottoms up then to take it from the top down, and say.
**Susan Daniels**: Have the money that I have i'm going to give you X amount of it to be able to get it done so, I want to introduce some concept to you call it a rough order of magnitude estimate okay.
**Susan Daniels**: The also referred to as a R O m okay rough order of magnitude also referred to as an ar m, you may see our oem in one of your pmi questions it's another commonly used acronym.
**Susan Daniels**: Please know that a rough order of magnitude is an educated guess Okay, it is more than a swag and maybe some of you know what a swag is but it swag stands for.
**Susan Daniels**: A guess and you're claiming that it's a guess that's what the G stands for.
**Susan Daniels**: And um yeah so when someone is thinking that you're not you're just kind of making up the number and you don't really have anything to base on.
**Susan Daniels**: And you're being challenged by your estimate in a meeting your read your reply your professional response is to say no, it is not some wild guess it is a rough order of magnitude estimate.
**Susan Daniels**: And as long as you feel like you, are within this range minus 25% to 75% and other words it could be a little less than what i'm saying it could be less but i'm being conservative here, it could actually be more, but this is a conservative rough order of magnitude estimate.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so i'm just know that you have a way of kind of still making broad swinging estimates, but you got to own it you got to say, this is a rough order of magnitude, but if you're more definitive now to be definitive you have to be plus or minus in this range okay that's typical.
**Susan Daniels**: You will see definitive estimates and wrong estimates as potential answers for you to choose from, and you just kind of need to know what that what that term is.
**Susan Daniels**: So when it comes to.
**Susan Daniels**: Project governance they're just simply not talking about how to build your project governance or how to engage your project governance thoroughly.
**Susan Daniels**: is just simply saying when you're planning your budget your project governance aka your sponsors Okay, and some key stakeholders may be in a position to guide you on your developing your budget, they may.
**Susan Daniels**: influence you on what kind of vendors or silicon that you want to go after they may have been influential and what kind of solution you choose.
**Susan Daniels**: Your project governance is your strongest resource in helping to lock your budget in from rough order of magnitude to more definitive they've got the expertise.
**Susan Daniels**: And they've got the authority to really help you lock in your final estimate okay on how you're going to arrive at it, it never hurts to ask questions on your budget.
**Susan Daniels**: Because honestly your sponsors they're, the ones who went out and got the money they're the ones that have the most at risk for this to be successful okay.
**Susan Daniels**: they're counting on you, and if you give them the opportunity, and then you empower them to make decisions with you on the budget.
**Susan Daniels**: They are much more likely to be your best Defense on when you're when you start running a little over under on budget they know how you got to it.
**Susan Daniels**: They helped you make those decisions they are your strongest ally so so lean into your governance don't think you have to sit at your desk figure it all out and then hope they like it right.
**Susan Daniels**: have a lot of arm exchanges going back and forth and.
**Susan Daniels**: You can do a lot of the research for the parametric and the analysis and get the information for bottoms up from your dictionaries and surveys.
**Susan Daniels**: You can tell them how you arrived at it your basis of estimates, but kind of want them engaged along the way, when you come up with the number, they need to buy in.
**Susan Daniels**: On what your basis of estimates are okay and and have them kind of approve it along the way, so when it's time to load and lock in the final budget they know how you got there and they're ready to approve it in a timely manner.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay let's see.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay Taylor cost estimate approach two phases of the project lifecycle okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So it has to do with kind of whether you're in initiating planning are in planning in initiating we were still just on at the hypothetical.
**Susan Daniels**: So you get one large number right of how much money to work with roughly eight and then at the next phase you're starting to work on the Charter, like the business cases one big number we're going for a million dollars right.
**Susan Daniels**: And then, at the Charter they realize that they got the million dollars, but they want to hold back some some management reserves, they want to, so they tell you only have eight 800,000.
**Susan Daniels**: Right that's your big number at the Charter level stay within 800,000 they're all in on a couple of hundred thousand for managing.
**Susan Daniels**: And then, as you start to build your budget, you may come in with going from rough order of magnitude down to more definitive that's what it means by phase in your life cycle from initiating down to planning your budget specificity, is going to increase.
**Susan Daniels**: Compliance compliance is one thing you have to be sure to include in your budget estimates it's not just the word packages that need to be done.
**Susan Daniels**: verify and re verify that you have compliance requirements definitely addressed and funded okay now, you may have to organize a whole.
**Susan Daniels**: aspect of your budget for just compliance, what are the permitting costs, what are the inspection cost right, it may be just a whole standalone sum of money right that needs to happen so.
**Susan Daniels**: don't overlook that particularly if you're new to an industry and you're not sure how regulatory Richard is on just always kind of top of line put compliance and then it might move down and how much it actually needs to be funded, but you don't want to forget that line item.
**Susan Daniels**: Yes, Stephen compliance will get you in trouble quicker than more than other aspects that's for sure.
**Susan Daniels**: um now as you go along, you want to make sure that you looked at past lessons learned from similar projects and you want to start your own lessons learned okay as you're going through.
**Susan Daniels**: Because, if you have to do this project again you want that Nice summary that one complete place to look for all of the issues and concerns that you addressed.
**Susan Daniels**: issue logs get produced each month right and they get sent up line and leadership looks at it, as a status report hey.
**Susan Daniels**: So if you are going to have to look at all the issues you have you might have 10 1215 months worth of issue logs to go find an aggregate.
**Susan Daniels**: Lessons learned is that running list that you're building in one place of all the issues and solutions that you implemented it's sort of that very concise summary.
**Susan Daniels**: um okay just be sure to keep your issues your lessons learned register up to date with your budgeting concerns as well okay here we're talking about estimating cost that's your guidance kind of a summary of things to take into consideration.
**Susan Daniels**: What I want to move on to, though, is estimating your budget, how do you kind of build a budget right you aggregate the estimated cost of individual activities or work packages, so I want to bring something down on out of your inbox.
**Susan Daniels**: It looks like this now, this is kind of on if you're looking at a phone is kind of hard to read so i'm going to go ahead and do the lecture points but i'm going to do it from a bigger version of it so hopefully you guys can see better.
**Susan Daniels**: Hopefully that's helpful.
**Susan Daniels**: Either proprietary issues with lessons learned access um it's all on how you set the administrative rights to the folder of wherever you're saving it so.
**Susan Daniels**: Lessons learned is you just you don't use specific names, you can use different vendors right um, but you can identify which one's worked really well and which ones, you would not recommend.
**Susan Daniels**: don't don't write anything this liable right, but just put would not recommend using xyz company going forward and period don't even go into explanation if somebody looks that up and once more detail, they can get the whispers behind it.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so most of the time we have been taught to read from right to left in the English language, and so I don't want you to look at this from right to left coming from left to write and tell them a little dyslexic.
**Susan Daniels**: we're going to look at this particular graphic going from the right to the left so don't watch my words watch my arrows we start over here.
**Susan Daniels**: When you're building your total project budget it's it's built in increments and one of the first things you do is for each activity, you get a cost estimate.
**Susan Daniels**: And you get those from your your survey document right the people doing the work for that work package tell you what activities it takes, then they can estimate for you what that activity will cost what resources they may need and the cost of those resources.
**Susan Daniels**: You some those activities together to get the cost for each word package so far, this makes sense right.
**Susan Daniels**: Now Venus is a some activity contingency reserve that's kind of built in okay.
**Susan Daniels**: When you're asking optimistic most likely pessimistic right when they add the three pointed often skews it a little bit towards the pessimistic those in okay that i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Extra buffer on the activity cost estimate, but when it comes to you some of those up into all of your work package cost estimates, but then it says, you have a contingency reserve on top of that okay.
**Susan Daniels**: That is based upon your risk register and when we get into risk registers you'll see a component of your risk register is to identify your response strategy.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, this response strategy, then you go further and say, well, what would it cost to implement that response What would it cost in time and what would it cost in in finances.
**Susan Daniels**: And you some all of that contingency estimates up and you get a grand total and then you go in and you negotiate to get as much of that contingency reserve estimate that you possibly can more on that to come.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, what is the difference between activity costs and work package cost activity contingency reserve.
**Susan Daniels**: you've got your activity cost estimates which you might have a little buffer built into that estimate.
**Susan Daniels**: You can put a specific activity contingency reserve, that is, if one particular activity, for example.
**Susan Daniels**: um you're flying somebody from place to place right and you need to make sure that they get there well you're going to have an estimate.
**Susan Daniels**: of how much that flights, going to be to fly them.
**Susan Daniels**: But you know that airline costs are very fluctuating right so you're going to put in a little contingency on just that activity and it's justifiable it's explainable and you can show the basis for it, but this is more the exception than the rule.
**Susan Daniels**: contingency reserve, this is for all projects Okay, this is the total contingency reserve, now the project manager has control over both the word package cost estimates money for them for the get the work done and they have authority over the contingency reserve in most projects.
**Susan Daniels**: Once you have those things identified, then you have to identify where are you going to put your control accounts what at what what are you going to monitor your.
**Susan Daniels**: on schedule, scope and cost all at the same time for performance reporting, so you kind of identify where you're going to report on so now you've built your budget and what kind of.
**Susan Daniels**: Shall we say um.
**Susan Daniels**: One way to put it is, are we gonna follow like that chart of accounts, which is my personnel costs my.
**Susan Daniels**: vendor costs my recent my printing costs my travel costs training costs you kind of a standard chart of accounts can be your control accounts.
**Susan Daniels**: Or, if you have a different configuration with your company, you may set up different control accounts but it's kind of deciding what the framework your budget looks like right, what is the framework of your budget.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, great you have now fundamentally built your cost baseline you have a budget proposal put together a budget plan yeah you okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But your total budget for your project may have one more aspect which you may or may not have information about.
**Susan Daniels**: Member how the business case got them a million dollars, but by the time it came to your charter I said you were told you only had 800,000 okay.
**Susan Daniels**: it's common practice in project management at the higher echelons when you're at portfolio and program management.
**Susan Daniels**: To hold back management reserves, so that if a project gets in trouble, you still can bail it out.
**Susan Daniels**: And you've made sure to senior leadership that you've not over promise and under deliver so they'll tell projects, they only have so much to get done to get things done let's see how much they can get for their money right.
**Susan Daniels**: But they also hold back somewhere between five and 20% for management reserves really depends on the industry depends on the size of the project.
**Susan Daniels**: If it anytime your boss your project actually has to go knocking and get management reserves, then that cost plus this cost becomes your total project cost Okay, but.
**Susan Daniels**: You may only see how much you have on your cost baseline, but please know in sophisticated companies and with organizations that have mature project management offices.
**Susan Daniels**: they're sitting on management reserves.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll pause for questions okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um let's see I want to show you a second thing.
**Susan Daniels**: If you understand, and you may see a chart similar to this in your test, you may or may not.
**Susan Daniels**: If the black line represents what your plan is what your basic plan is your budget at completion this point represents your budget at completion Okay, and this is your actual expenditures, this is what really is happening on your project.
**Susan Daniels**: Your funding requirements for funding reconciliation is basically you can spend more money than you have available to you at the time.
**Susan Daniels**: You have to stay within your funding limits in huge projects, sometimes money is only released in quarters Okay, or only released.
**Susan Daniels**: On when, as the banking finance has become available, so you have to make sure your work and spend stays Within those limits, this is extremely common in construction okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So you have certain times, where you get releases of money, if you will Okay, and as you see your plan always matches the availability of the funds.
**Susan Daniels**: Now you're told you build your maximum budget here, and you have management reserves sitting on top of it which you may or may not know how much is sitting there available to you.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm willing to bet a box of donuts you're never told okay it's sort of something that is kept close to the chest, so people don't take advantage of it or make presumptions.
**Susan Daniels**: If you were this project manager, would you be proud of your project results.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh good we don't have a consensus going through good i'm glad that we're seeing different answers okay yeah Okay, maybe somebody's hedging their bets either way okay.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So remember how we hang our reputation on being on time on budget, you know delivering what is X four and at the quality expectations okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So here we have this plan and all along i'm way under budget right i'm not spending the money, the way that I have projected that I would okay so i've got a lot of explaining to do i'm not using the money that I asked for right.
**Susan Daniels**: Now it's not bad, to say that you got up you know, a positive variance and that you know those resources.
**Susan Daniels**: weren't totally required, but you do that long enough people are going to kind of get the impression that you.
**Susan Daniels**: Over pad your budget it's not good for your reputation right you want to be much closer to plan you can be will be a little over and a little under and a little over for reporting cycles petition be much closer to this line than this particular project manager s.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay now we're getting close to the end and then all of a sudden you're expecting the senior leadership is expecting this project, maybe even give them some money to help another project out.
**Susan Daniels**: I mean the whole thing you guys have been running under budget right, so we get to the end it's the last quarter re projections senior leadership scaling you know susie's budget.
**Susan Daniels**: susie's projects been running under budgets, probably going to come in under budget and then she Zam at the end not only blows her budget right she's got to come knocking to take money out of.
**Susan Daniels**: Management reserves, this one was totally unexpected right there's really not an indicator.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, if you were running close to and then starting to run it over and it was foreseeable you're going to stay running over well, then they be ready for you at the end they be expecting you at the end.
**Susan Daniels**: But this one is sort of like kind of just goes the wrong way at the end so overall not particularly well done in the budgeting right and in the execution.
**Susan Daniels**: They may give you a chart similar to this, but the line may look different and they're going to ask you if this was a favorable or unfavorable result.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, are the funds web quarterly from the PMs budget of under budget on typically not.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes organizations get into trouble and one of the places they have to keep the operations guy come on that's what you know they're delivering to the customer so they'll keep operations going.
**Susan Daniels**: at the expense of project budget because project budget is generally capability investment so they can wait on their capabilities.
**Susan Daniels**: Why they keep the business running they may stall projects right, but when they actually sweep the money that's not a good sign for the rest of your year Okay, because when they sweep the money out of the arm the projects.
**Susan Daniels**: With a with a awful and it's just say you still have that much allocated we're just stopping for now right and they'll redeploy the resources to something different.
**Susan Daniels**: Is management reserves, there was a question about management reserves earlier um is that money already set aside at the beginning of the year, yes Okay, as soon as your project has been set okay and go.
**Susan Daniels**: well run organizations will have already calculated what the management reserve is relative to the to the project so yeah it's sitting there you just not may not know that it's.
**Susan Daniels**: been set aside now as you rise in the ranks in your your profession learn from this anytime that you have projects underneath you hold back some management reserves okay.
**Susan Daniels**: All right, we're moving I need to move on.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay let's minimize this.
**Susan Daniels**: Budget challenges well we're going to see a variety of budget challenges right it's it's what we we work with um.
**Susan Daniels**: um i'll let you read this slide while I answer a question or two.
**Susan Daniels**: Susan you briefly mentioned various does this have to do with the deviation between planned and actual yes that's what i'm talking about you don't want to have a wide variance from your plan.
**Susan Daniels**: That otherwise we're just going to think you're really not that good consistently wide variance either over budget and are under budget and kind of says that you need to work on your your cost estimating approaches.
**Susan Daniels**: So what we showed on the screen, the budget, the budget illustration I just talked about someone asked was that favorable or unfavorable that was unfavorable on many counts okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Good plan for cost reconciliation, but on execution was unfavorable.
**Susan Daniels**: So, because the funding limitations really had to do with making sure that your plan stayed within the release amounts that you had available to you, and when that funding was going to be available that's all it's really talking about okay.
**Susan Daniels**: It really happens on a much larger budgets if you're working on small projects that happened within your operating team then it's just that money's been set aside at the beginning of the year.
**Susan Daniels**: And you're good to go, but if you're doing multi year and you're doing where the funding is coming from outside the organization and they've done bank loans or selling notes or something to that effect.
**Susan Daniels**: Then you've got to really take into account funding limit reconciliation.
**Susan Daniels**: They bring this to your attention because remember you're going to be a project management, professional and you're supposed to be able to run multimillion dollar projects multi year projects with hundreds of people.
**Susan Daniels**: that's the scope and scale that once you master these techniques, you should be able to do.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: This is a guideline is just in that handy desk reference and trying to mask build your master plan and run your project is just giving you a whole card saying you know anticipate you're going to have budget challenges and put those into your contingency.
**Susan Daniels**: This is your checklist kind of summarizes what we just talked about.
**Susan Daniels**: Now.
**Susan Daniels**: I will see if there is one more question beef question to you, before I go into the next topic which is planning man is quality of deliverables.
**Susan Daniels**: Actually, this is a great point we're just going to take a break here before we jump into this and we'll just finish up the last hour talking about quality so let's just go ahead and set up a 15 minute break and stretch your legs get on get ready to start talking about quality.